FORMER U.S. AMBASSADOR JAPAN UP
AGAINST TRAUMA SURGEON MICHAEL M
SETHY.
KRISTIN FISHER TELLS US WHY.
>> VICE PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE
VENTING HIS FRUSTRATION WITH
CHIEF JUSTICE JOHN ROBERTS FOR
SIDING WITH THE SUPREME COURT’S
LIBERAL JUSTICES IN A STRING OF
RECENT DEFEATS FOR THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
FROM UPHOLDING THE DACA PROGRAM
FOR UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS TO
EXTENDING PROTECTIONS TO LGBTQ
WORKERS.
THE CHIEF JUSTICE ALSO RULED
AGAINST THE CHURCH IN NEVADA
FIGHTING FOR MORE THAN 50 PEOPLE
TO ATTEND SERVICES IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE PANDEMIC.
AND HE STRUCK DOWN A LOUISIANA
LAW REQUIRING ABORTION PROVIDERS
TO HAVE ADMITTING PRIVILEGES AT
LOCAL HOSPITALS.
>> I THINK IT’S BEEN A WAKE-UP
CALL FOR PRO-LIFE VOTERS AROUND
THE COUNTRY WHO UNDERSTAND IN A
VERY REAL SENSE THE DESTINY OF
THE SUPREME COURT IS ON THE
BALLOT IN 2020.
>> SO FAR THE CHIEF JUSTICE HAS
NOT RESPONDED TO THE VICE
PRESIDENT’S CRITICISM NOR DID HE
REACT WHEN PRESIDENT TRUMP
CALLED HIS 2012 DECISION TO
UPHOLD OBAMACARE DISGRACEFUL.
BUT IN 2018, ROBERTS DID ISSUE A
RARE REBUKE AFTER PRESIDENT
TRUMP REFERRED TO A FEDERAL
JUDGE AS AN OBAMA JUDGE, ROBERTS
WROTE IN PART, QUOTE:  WE DO NOT
HAVE OBAMA JUDGES OR TRUMP
JUDGES.
BUSH JUDGES OR CLINTON JUDGES.
THAT INDEPENDENT JUDICIARY IS
SOMETHING WE SHOULD ALL BE
THANKFUL FOR.
>> PEOPLE NEED TO KNOW THAT WE
ARE NOT DOING POLITICS.
THEY NEED TO KNOW THAT WE ARE
DOING SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
THAT WE’RE APPLYING THE LAW.
>> THIS TERM ROBERT SOLIDIFIED
HIS ROLE AS THE COURT’S ANCHOR
JUSTICE BY SIDING WITH THE
MAJORITY IN 58 OF 60 CASES.
THAT’S MORE THAN ANY OTHER
JUSTICE.
>> HE HAS A HISTORY OF BEING A
VERY IMPARTIAL, FAIR, ALMOST
UMPIRE LIKE JUSTICE WHO CALLS
THEM AS HE SEES THEM.
>> BUT THE PRESIDENT PUTS
LOYALTY TO CONSERVATISM AT THE
TOP OF THE LIST WHEN CONSIDERING
NEW JUDICIAL APPOINTEES.
HE HAS ALREADY GOTTEN 200
CONFIRMED.
THAT’S A RECORD.
FOR A FIRST-TERM PRESIDENT.
AND JUST LIKE DID HE IN 2016, HE
IS NOW PROMISING TO RELEASE A
NEW LIST OF POTENTIAL NOMINEES
TO THE SUPREME COURT IF HE